en el vídeo pasado teníamos este aparato
que le había llamado un conmutador que
tenía unas clavijas especiales de hecho
se llaman escobillas es el nombre formal
y son muy parecidas a las escobillas que
se utilizan en este juego de los
carritos cómo se llama así de los
carritos chocones los carritos chocones
entonces déjame dibujar un carrito
chocón nada más por diversión voy a
pintar con color verde entonces ahí está
el carrito chocón que parece un zapato
imagínate que tú estás ahí
estás muy feliz entonces las escobillas
son estas mismas cosas que están en el
extremo del carrito chocón y que hacen
contacto con el techo para que pase una
corriente hacia el carrito eso tiene
muchas utilidades porque permite que
este carrito se mueva sin necesidad de
que traiga una pila cargando eso está
padre por qué porque si no sería muy
latosos ponerle una pila a cada uno o
una batería y sería muy peligroso pero
bueno nada más quería darte esto de la
terminología
este es un conmutador estas son
escobillas y bueno ven siempre es bueno
poner como ejemplo a los carritos
chocones creo que hubiera sido bueno
mencionarlos en mecánica clásica pero
bueno regresando al problema entonces lo
que te contaba es que utilizando las
reglas de la mano derecha de nuevo
teníamos un giro en esta dirección
verdad y el campo magnético ejercía una
fuerza aquí hacia adentro y de este lado
hacia afuera por lo tanto se creaba un
torque y empezaba a girar y llegábamos a
esta posición en donde ya lo marque con
colores verdad aquí tenemos el lado
verde que es este lado
de acá debería pintarlo
y aquí quedaron un poquito más largo y
de este lado tenemos el lado rosa lado
rosa que llegó a esta posición entonces
bueno imagínate no sé que este o sea si
estas distancias de r entonces aquí está
el eje y este lado está en r de
profundidad y el lado morado está r así
hacia afuera y re hacia atrás pero bueno
lo que sucede en este momento es que
nuestra parte de abajo del circuito
pierde contacto con las escobillas
entonces en este momento no hay nada de
corriente estamos ahorrando un poquito
de pila verdad y lo que estamos haciendo
es permitir que el momento angular haga
que esto gire un poquito más entonces va
a seguir girando y va a seguir girando
hasta que llegamos a una nueva posición
deja la pongo entonces va a seguir
girando hasta que llegamos a esta
posición por aquí tenemos la parte de
arriba
más o menos así por allí están las
escobillas aquí tenemos la pila más
menos entonces ahora tenemos algo de
estoy dibujando el circuito y otra vez
una escobilla entonces ahora tenemos
algo de este estilo entonces qué sucede
en este momento pues otra vez el
conmutador nos permite el flujo de
corriente pero como aquí sigue siendo
más aquí - la corriente sigue yendo así
va sigue yendo en esta dirección
pero ahora que el lado es cual lado
después veo sea estoy acá que era el
lado derecho ahora se convierte en el
lado izquierdo porque dio media vuelta
en el circuito entonces llegó hasta acá
y el lado izquierdo ahora es el lado
derecho se convierte en este lado verde
va y entonces yo digo que ahora sí van a
pasar cosas padres porque mira aquí hay
algo interesante antes lo que sucedía
cuando dábamos una vuelta de 180 grados
es que la corriente pues seguía fluyendo
y digamos primero pasando por el verde y
luego por el morado entonces lo o sea la
costa esa que teníamos antes no rota va
nada más oscilaba así como que se
volteaba para un lado y para el otro
para un lado y para el otro y entonces
eso estaba útil para no ser digamos
voltear tortillas pero no estaba útil
para hacer un motor ahora qué pasa pues
ahora al conectarlo así con estas
clavijas con estas escobillas tenemos
que la corriente sigue yendo primero
pasando por el lado izquierdo que ahora
es el morado y luego por el lado derecho
que ahora es el verde entonces otra vez
tenemos usando
regla de la mano derecha que aquí esta
cosa ahora está bueno este campo
magnético ahora está ejerciendo una
fuerza así hacia adentro y del lado
derecho ahora ejerce una fuerza hacia
afuera y por lo tanto tenemos un torque
en la misma dirección que lo teníamos
desde el principio otra vez estamos
girando así volvemos a la posición
inicial y por lo tanto va a seguir
pasando esto de que giramos en este
sentido bueno creo que hacer círculos no
ayuda mucho en la pantalla pero se
entiende verdad más o menos aquí sale y
aquí entra entonces qué pasa ahora si
logramos crear un motor eléctrico
eso está súper padre vale entonces como
fue la idea teníamos este circuito de
acá teníamos un campo magnético lo que
hicimos fue crear un conmutador que
corta la corriente al llegar a los 90
grados a través de unas escobillas
especiales
y eso lo que logra hacer es que cuando
lleguemos a esta posición la corriente
se invierte en el sentido de que ahora
pasa primero en vez de por este y luego
por este primero por este y luego por
este entonces eso logra hacer que del
lado izquierdo siempre siempre entre la
fuerza y del lado derecho siempre salga
y siga girando y entonces con esto ya
podemos poner una rueda aquí y hacer
girar un coche o podemos poner unas
aspas y tener una licuadora vaya esto
está padrísimo va entonces esto de acá
es el principio básico de un motor
eléctrico y casi todos los motores
eléctricos funcionan así en realidad hay
otras formas de arreglar el problema así
por ejemplo podríamos no sé a lo mejor
apagar el campo magnético y esperar
hasta que gire toda la vuelta completa
eso podría ser una opción pero se
enredan los cables podríamos tener
problemas o bien podríamos cambiar la
dirección del campo magnético no sé a lo
mejor a hacer algún otro invento para
cambiar la dirección que no sean
precisamente escobillas pero bueno estas
ya son modificaciones estoy acá es la
idea así más básica es algo muy sencillo
y creo que da la idea
de cómo funcionan los motores eléctricos
ya después podemos construir sobre esta
idea sencilla a meter la innovación
hacerlo más eficiente y bueno crear
muchísimo valor en el mundo pero bueno
no está padre esto está padrísimo no es
súper padre poder ver que algo de física
pues nos ayuda para hacer algo útil